hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast
whistleblower this amazing addition on
to outlast and I kind of forgot where I
was going because I played yesterday and
I took a break because me and the
buddies that are coming down everyone's
was that nothing again is that a whole
lot of nothing because I remember there
was something there was nothing before
so if that's nothing again then I don't
want to worry about it ever but anyway
all the games here Bob Waits indigo
they're all here and they're all
downstairs actually waiting for me to
finish playing this so that we can get
to more sketch comedy videos we just
recorded this amazing video that you
guys are gonna absolutely love and I
have no idea where I'm going now all
that noise with the thing was that all a
lot of nothing again sure is a lot of
nothing going around here oh what's that
that thing oh it's just more batteries
god there's a lot of electronics just
sitting around why would there be
electronics just sitting around an
asylum a mental asylum hospital then
it's just a pile of trash and garbage
well what am I supposed to do I couldn't
go back and I can't go forward
wait a minute it's got to be like
another another Avenue that I can take
here bear with me here I mean bathroom
oh okay I'm stupid
once again I can't realize that I just
need to climb over some things and I'll
be able to go on my merry way but
unfortunately this game is throwing me
curveballs when I my brain is just too
smart to get there complex puzzles I'm
too good is happening what is going on
who the hell are you why do you have a
buzzsaw can I see that booty
can you come lead it around the corner
again I want to get a better look at it
but do you have the booty of another man
that you just cut it off of are you the
crazed Bunch dapper I spit on my foe boy
that those brass I really do like to
pump up the atmosphere this game doesn't
rely on a string quartet oh my back just
how does a guy playing a sousaphone in
my ear stop that sousaphone man don't
you be Susan me I know it was over there
I'm not gonna oh hello spy
like my man well there is a dude there
hi bro you can't see me can you okay oh
it's probably precariously me dude what
are you doing those stupid [ __ ] your
constructor get off my nuts I'm going
I'm going for it okay I guess he didn't
need a panic because he wasn't exactly
behind me okay okay
all the area's half-friend oh you are
awesome and also disturbing where do I
go oh okay
Soph close this down didn't hear nothing
a whole lot of nothing
okay Oh what is going on oh I need to
reload the batteries god it's so nice to
have a well made horror game was it
something over here what am i doing why
am I going it's a mirror dude Zamir do
where am I going
don't open it calmly feed me Seymour
feed me and now thank you sir you got
plenty of food as it is oh wait I'm
going backwards
back dari god damn it he's catching me
all over the place I don't know where
I'd better go now goodbye hello goodbye
oh sorry sorry sorry I apologize I
apologize sincerely for everything I've
done in my life dude no no no no thank
you thank you very much I would rather
not because it's got to be a way that I
can go up or something something that
I've missed something very obvious good
god stop it man I'm just trying to get
by I need to find what I need what do i
do what do i do I don't know what to do
you son of a [ __ ] you better let me go
down whoosh what the hell am I supposed
to do I can't get away from em for two
goddamn seconds close it I am [ __ ] fine
so you can't oh no you do not yeah I'm
not in that one you douche you pick the
wrong one
what a loser loser is anything right
hell I do not like that guy Sam I am
that does not rhyme and I don't eat yams
all right
I'm guessing is just not gonna leave oh
come on
damn it mother humping piece of ass
where do I go where do I go I even
looked up before I'm such a [ __ ] god
I'm an idiot
ah okay up up up up I gotta go up I
gotta go up everybody how did I not how
did I not get that cuz I am an idiot
that's a liar okay take two okay so this
time oh god damn it again yeah okay so I
just got to open the door closer by me
be done with it close it close it
don't lackadaisically open doors up over
oh hi no your friend that was dear
friend last time yeah what's that it's a
secret
oh no I'm not scared what are you scared
no how about a whole lotta no wait am i
back to the same place I was before
I keep looping around and around oh
here's the keys to the hangar
no you know what's happening back no you
know I am NOT your friend get away from
it you're weird
they're really weird not scared you
didn't even pass it down Oh Joey please
I do not like you what that guy that
guy's got to be the creepiest son of a
[ __ ] I've ever seen in any horror game
anywhere what is that oh I missed a
battery over there but I'm okay I can
deal oh you son of an assbag
when oh wow don't you do that knock out
who are you are you the friend guy or
you saw a guy eyes I saw a guy
okay I might have overreacted a little
bit there I apologize
didn't mean to sorry dead guy so that
guy's the new what's-his-face the big
guy from before I don't remember his
actual name
oh hi are you the one that uh gave me
that anesthetic last time are you the
son of a [ __ ] I should blame for that
ordeal oh man I think he found another
way
Yeah right god damn it let's devil a
more presents
I feel the stress of you hunting me you
son of a [ __ ]
okay crematorium
it's Ryan remitting Christmas good god
no thank you
Miami Wiesel
what do i do what do I do
okay I see ah no no I am mine you cannot
have my body no one gonna have my body
you would take it in a very literal
sense and I don't let you pretty oh
you're coming in here aren't you are you
I went in a dead end what do I do about
that
is this a dinner I probably shouldn't be
wasting this much time why it's gonna
carry on who do you think you are you
think this is vanish get out of here
with that steamy crap grating over here
okay
god it's easy to miss details in the
dark I apologize if I seem like an idiot
because I am but also it's very easy to
miss stuff it was their purpose - that
up look up up up up up up up up maybe
something is up above no not a ninguna
absolutely not okay those are point to
that Ray once there was that I mistaken
this way it looks good see an exit sign
yeah yeah yeah change the battery well
I'm not gonna be smart and go towards
the exit sign I'm gonna go over here
with it's creepy better stolen great be
Church with that priest guy probably is
hanging about he's got a lot of pictures
of himself that's quite nice that's very
nice
I'm out here oh well crap I guess I
shouldn't have expected it to be that
easy so uh so what about this is this
just taunting me you just a son of a
[ __ ] wants to show me an exit that I
can actually have there's actually
something every oh there we go
here we go J father Clarke far be it for
me to lie to a man of God so let me at
least say that I will do my personal
best to improve the safety of your
working conditions I and the rest of the
staff truly appreciate everything you do
for our patients and if you feel
threatened by anybody in particular
simply let us know and we can either
increase chemical restraints or
administer a lobotomy or similar
commonly similar calming procedure don't
underestimate the convenience of your
sermons offer our patients especially
considering the depth and necessarily
chaotic nature of hypnotherapy our
patients need the bedrocks of God and
family not all of our poor unfortunates
have families to call upon and so the
burden and calling is yours we are all
of us relying on your faith and hard
work was that good for you
you turn the priests sky psycho bunkers
crazy just along with everybody else now
he needs to lead his flock astray which
is good I guess
so oh that's right I'm supposed to go oh
I got it now thank you thank you thank
you for that thank you for the little
clue all I needed to do is look up it's
getting in that habit now all right come
on up you don't up there climbing is
your game now Oh care of your uh gotta
save techie you gotta get gone man now
this is more appropriate to what I think
would actually happen in the horror
scenario like the situation would call
for extreme adrenaline and a lot of
running and you'd be surprised at what a
human can do even if he's out of shape
when he's afraid fighter flight is very
powerful - okay
whoa what is happening boy okay alright
I'm not gonna question it oh boy my
hypnotherapy could kick it in again
alright
Oh down here okay this time I gotta look
down to where I'm supposed to go there's
got hurt yeah I didn't feel it why am I
still like a journalist my shadows still
holding this oblique weight I got a
camera better record this for
everybody's posterity well I guess if
you could you would I guess it's a guess
if it was the only way that you can see
you would hello anybody any diabolical
monsters you might walk which way is
that coming from because I need to know
and now would be a good time okay jeez
how much can that guy eat why what is on
the ground on the ceiling why does
everything already look so decrepit the
cow is this acceptable working
conditions for anyone here not the right
questions I should be out did I just
lock myself in here with Oh
okay can I come with you
there seems to be a psycho murderer here
was it kind of eat my bones I keep
telling them that bones aren't that
tasty he insists like my shoulders are
hurt from being so tense I'm looking at
constant state no yeah god dammit you
mother humping humper from where did you
all God you came that way no you came no
no
run run you douche I need to go that way
excuse me pardon me excuse me pardon me
pardon me excuse me pardon me pardon me
pardon me pardon me
there's only a matador there pardon
pardon pardon pardon pardon pardon
pardon pardon pardon pardon it's gonna
run this way thank you very much no no
it'll be all right that's good oh good
that's good that's real good oh good oh
my god seriously my shoulders killing me
all of this entire playthrough I've been
what's gonna happen to me oh my god I
have had a game to make me feel this
tense in a long time
oh man this is awesome oh there's a hole
here ha I love it
sorry ok I'll get to that in like a few
hours just give me some time I'm some
busy man you know I got a lot of stuff
to do I got a lot on my plate if you
could just you know sit tight
influencing human behavior the potential
use of psycho chemicals in political
Ashkan operates as well operations as
well as recognized although it's not
been explored as thoroughly as might be
expected chemical division includes it
as an objective of its program to be
prepared to support and make such
operations possible non-chemical methods
of accomplishing political action
operations are also included in the
program present the above McCullough
excerpt to Technical Services Division
for budgeting and authorization of
continued research into research of dr.
Rudolf Warnecke and Project walrider
okay so that's talking about the stuff
that led up to all this nastiness the
human experimentation and trying to
reach
hold on for two seconds there I got a
bone to pick with you okay
good talk oh I moved his door so sorry
that was my bad I probably scared him
probably maybe you have fun yeah fun
buddy do I do here god damn it the jump
scares are so good in this game I can't
even complain about him it's so well
made ah it's so unexpected and not
cliched hello you want to okay I can't
surprise you again okay just gonna carry
on whoo and this game does actually have
good pacing because there are periods of
high moments and then it calms down for
a bit like the chase scenes are pretty
good but uh hoes Emmy so that meant one
of the room numbers was calling so one
of these rooms has someone calling for
help okay let's have been down there
okay there's a red light down there okay
okay I got it got it got it I'm piecing
it ah god damn it [ __ ]
the piece of ass come on buddy got a
dough we got dough you a big baby what
do you got though we don't go yeah hop
over that hop over this Oh
my nards I think he's chopped off
everything below the waist okay close
this off what do I do here oh oh
come on yes climb up not dead yet just
very much losing blood ah okay I get it
I get it I get what I need to do squeeze
a little [ __ ] you no no little piggy go
home little piggy little piggy little
piggy no no no no no no little piggy
gotta go go okay all right
I heard a laugh but I think it was
coming from downstairs as opposed to
right here all right
yeah those definitely downstairs I think
what happened whatever where who did
what
let me grab over there someone there did
someone do something I didn't see it I
didn't catch it what happened oh good
I'm back in the labs this is exactly
where I've wanted to be never thought
that Project walrider douche would have
been a better alternative than this guy
all right let me read this no not in
this episode here cuz I'm re
minimal morphogenetic Engine activity on
and only at extreme levels of hormone
therapy dream states return repeatedly
the images of isolation in betrayal zero
lucid state heavy bronchial accumulation
consistent with patients of histories of
tobacco and marijuana especially
exceptionally low REM activity Frank
concerning drinking blood from the chest
of sleeping men he continues to refuse
baths or the attention of a barber
outside the general ascent anesthesia
stating if I cannot partake I cannot
share recommend forced nutrition for mr.
manera if we cannot find him something
he likes to eat I think I know who this
guy is he found something that he enjoys
to eat I think his name was mr. manera
maybe Frank was his first name good to
meet you Frank go to hell alright so
that's all the time I got for this
episode thank you guys so much for
watching
gods I loved every moment of this if
you're enjoying this series please leave
a like to let me know let me know what
you think in the comments below and
as always I will say you in the next
video